good morning Millennials welcome back to
the morning toasters
today I'm calling it the morning letdown
because I am just here to talk about all
the things that are letting me down what
I mean he just got back from vacation
okay went to Eurovision I did let's
start with sympathy love your new
necklace oh my gosh thank you you know I
went out looking for the biggest star I
could find okay I know by the way I
actually have one if you wanted to
borrow do you I do I just that's what
you know you set out to a foreign
country with one thing specifically and
I was like I want the biggest like I'm a
big Jew in your face for everyone this
week was messaging me like you charity
Jew you know like I got this necklace
gonna have 200 shekels [ __ ] it's really
cute so I was I was running late today
because I was took a bad route to get
here so I haven't caught up with you I
know and also I got home like at 1:00 in
the morning how was your trip my trip
was I haven't spoken to you since we did
the podcast I didn't but other like
talking to no other than text like I
didn't call you up and say how's your
trip the trip was great I did not get
like nearly as tan as I intended to like
everyone in her than you everyone in
Israel like at the pool they were like
oh you American you have to put on
sunblock like literally people were
coming up to me they're like you're
American right cuz I was just like
laying out she put on sunblock the first
day I got I got nothing then a couple of
next days I'm like [ __ ] god I'm not
putting on sunblock I said I didn't even
get burned I don't get nothing I was
gonna say that's the thing about
sunblock like it actually works the Sun
yeah it's crazy well I had a great time
you know it was part cultural I was with
TPG Brian who had never been to Israel
and he was doing all the tourist things
I didn't go to all them with him because
once you've done it once it's like a lot
of work I'm not climbing Masada at 6:00
in the morning did he do it yes what'd
he think he loved it he loves stuff like
that but to see he couldn't get over
like the historical significance of the
country for so many different groups of
people agree and I was like that's what
I try and tell everyone and he was like
really felt so powerful from the western
wall and he did all types of he went to
Bethlehem visited you know the morgue
where Kim had North baptized he went to
East Jerusalem he went to Tel Aviv like
he really experienced all he was there
for nine days I was only there for six
but he really did like if you're gonna
travel travel with TPG because it's
honestly unlike any other experience
I've ever had in my life
so overall overall it was a great trip I
mean I'm exhausted I think I don't want
to jinx it on the way there I can
circumvented jet lag it's a seven-hour
time difference and I was feeling really
proud of myself
today I think I also did but I'll see
how I'm sure we'll just be tired tonight
whenever you come back from a sir you
always wake up really early that's the
clock that you're on but that's if you
take the midnight flight which is what
everyone takes but TVG opened my eyes to
a new time usually everyone goes there
they get on the 11 p.m. flight and they
come back on the 11 p.m. flight so you
can sleep the whole time but on the way
there it's like you take the 11 p.m.
flight you sleep for 8 hours and then
you wake up it's 10:00 p.m. so it's like
that [ __ ] you up so I took the 5
o'clock I had dinner
I watched Mean Girls and then I fell
asleep for like 6 or 7 hours and he woke
up and it was 11 a.m. like that's
perfect and I really didn't feel I took
one nap like I didn't feel anything yeah
this time I had like a little bit of a
like a clamped situation but I realized
that listening to other people's tales
of jet lag it's like not interesting but
I want to break Eurovision because Tel
Aviv hosted Eurovision this year which
is why me and TPG went I had never been
before I knew nothing about it like so
it's like American Idol for all the
countries and yes countries it's like
the Olympics of America but it's like a
huge deal like if you win like it's
lanes young one it can change your life
like okay and so I was just really
excited like I had no stake and I was
voting for Israel but like they're not
gonna win they just won I was just like
really there to enjoy and like be
spectator and it was very cool like I
mean you know me I love singing
competitions cuz I think that I should
be in one so it was really just I'd love
to hearing people saying that and the
songs are so good like they're I'm
surprised that those songs don't get
more popular because there was like a
couple bangers in there I could see us
like driving up to camp toes this
weekend listening to you know what's top
down but I had an experience that I want
to talk about and I'm you know what I'm
in the name of James Charles and talk to
you like I am receipts and I'm saying
names because I feel like it and I
really I really hope we have some
toasters in the Netherlands because I
have many a thought on the Netherlands
let me just start by saying I was
rooting for the guy from the Netherlands
that song is so beautiful Ben is 100%
convinced it's a Ryan Tedder song that
he played dries but still the guy has an
amazing voice I've been story ya know
I'm really like I thought the song was
great and it's a four-hour thing it's
two hours of performances and then they
have like a special system for judging
it's like all this the panelists judge
it's like a whole thing some of the
judging I was at the bar and I'm sitting
x2 the sky the bar and he's from the
Netherlands and I had a feeling he was
famous because like people kept coming
up and like being like oh like they had
like a respect from like seeing his hair
lady
pictures I later looked him up and he's
like a singer slash radio personality in
the Netherlands who has many times you
know fallen prey to the victim to the
treacherous nests of anti-semitism this
was not his first rendezvous with
anti-semitism and you know I never
really I don't think he's the
anti-semite yeah I know I would phrase
that was a victim he's the anti-semites
perpetrator of anti seventies a
perpetrator
okay you know what I think like I before
this thought I had look experienced
anti-semitism like in my face before but
I don't think I have I think the I mean
we've grew up like everyone I know is
Jewish and I think in New York it's like
a very Jew friendly so I've never
experienced like blatant anti-semitism
like spoke into my face and I was not
prepared in any way and if I could go
back I would have I handled it totally
differently course but I just it was in
that moment I realized like oh my god
I've never really experienced like
something so blatantly like bigoted I'm
like oh I first first I was like no he
couldn't have just said that so here's
what happened I'm sitting you know me I
find a chair anywhere and I'm sitting
and there's two guys from the
Netherlands they're blonde and they're
like decked out in the Netherlands like
sparkled shirts that they made the guy
who ended up being the guy his name is
Gordon he's like a famous singer it's
just he just he's like Madonna Gordon
and he's also like a radio personality
who said something really derogatory to
Barbra Streisand once um and we're like
he was so drunk literally has the worst
breath like out of all the things he did
his breath was the most offensive okay
and he's like sitting we're sitting at a
table like I'm calling for Brian like
we're like together but like not you
know we're just like sitting at the same
table as a small table and him and I
like just start talking you know me I'm
like I make friends wherever I go and
big mistake and we're just like chatting
or whatever and he does the weirdest
thing like he's talking with his friend
and like I'm like a part of the
conversation but not really you know
he's like you know like he's trying to
make a joke you know so here's a soda
bottle it was an orange soda he takes
the cap off of his bottle he puts it on
his nose and he's like shabbat shalom
and I'm like um why I was like that's
like kind of like anti-semitic like but
I was like I must have misunderstood I
was like there's no way that like in Tel
Aviv I'm wearing my bin Jew necklace
that this guy's gonna say anything I'm
like I must have missed like a first
half of the joke I was like a little
caught off guard where I'm like it can't
be it can't like there's no
then literally five minutes later I'm
calling Brian I'm like Brian Brian right
so Brian comes over me and Brian are
joking about something like they're half
listening to my conversation now and I'm
like oh my god Brian you're such a [ __ ]
and they're like think that it's so
funny that I called someone a [ __ ] and
they're like oh my god you filthy and
then they didn't say anything and they
both started hysterical that be to each
other what do you finish that sentence
with you filthy Jew now I didn't say
anything there because I wasn't sure
right like no and technically
technically say it but it was the first
thing that really made me think like
this guy has like really casual
anti-semitism like in his blood and
there's literally no doubt in my mind
that he was gonna say Jew but he didn't
and I wasn't like about to start a scene
so I just like Google to him afterwards
I took a couple pictures of him like for
my like self the next morning just to
remember what he looks like
and I didn't I like in a court of law
like I don't really have any hard
evidence that he was any choice I might
but like I you could feel it you know
oh yeah no you can definitely feel it um
that that's really disgusting I know
Chris I'm remembering my experiences
when you know you know that's the thing
it's like I don't have any proof except
that thing the bottle on the notes like
you're making your nose big like Jews
have big noses ha ha ha like that I
could almost understand someone like
trying to make a joke it's like that's a
joke a Jewish person should make it's
like you certainly can't say it with
your blonde hair but I don't know him
what did he say to Barbra Streisand oh
actually a Ben sent me the article
because I was like so like upset about
it and then did a whole Google search on
him okay Gordon talks about Jews it's
from oh oh org website so it's legit and
it goes like this this is his name
Cornelis Wellum
flicker Roth also known as a singer
Gordon as astonished she express himself
in an interview on the Amsterdam news
channel 85 the anchorman okay whatever
mmm Gordon said that the reason Barbra
Streisand has arrived in Amsterdam was
yes it seems to me that she needs money
she is right I would do the same thing
if I was in her stead the inner route in
an interview asks because she's 71
Gordon interrupts in the middle of a
sentence and says quite typical for Jews
do you really think that's a good reason
it's a good idea to scrape some more
money okay I had a feeling about this
guy I experienced it and I did
research and I feel justified oh my god
so it really opened my eyes to a new
experience that I've never experienced
before much less I planned on
experiencing in the Holy Land of Israel
the Jewish homeland right so that's my
story and I'm sticking to me okay that's
your big takeaway from the trip we
missed you here it was a snitch on the
toast weak situation see just on the
garlic garlic bread and a nice omelet
baguette and it was a great week
Mitchell Mitchell Mitchell Tenpenny was
here was he the cutest man ever he was
so freaking cute oh my god on Friday I
was such a freak because we were he was
on the show we were talking about his
concert that night and I was saying
snitch was going I was like oh I can't
come because I have an engagement and I
meant it like I have a prior engagement
but then I really had Sam's engagement
and instead of like pivoting I was like
because I haven't in gained Oh watch out
did you watch it toast she didn't watch
it until this morning okay I knew she
was getting engaged like an hour later
so I knew we would be okay and like
there was no way she's gonna listen to
it but I was just like dying and then I
I mean like no one in the room knew why
I was being a freak and so it was just
so awkward so Mitchell to have anything
sure freak yeah I explained him after so
I think moved it over and then after his
concert like we actually hadn't been
fighting him to the engagement so it all
came full circle okay that's good so
anyways it was it was a great week it
was a great weekend Sam got engaged just
I just love love love love it's like you
know what I love when girls get engaged
or they just show up with like the
perfect white dress I'm like you've had
that in your closet for a month oh no
even better so the engagement party was
at bar at a hotel and her mom brought us
upstairs like to see her just getting
ready before she went down to the party
and she had a closet full of white
dresses I'm sure that her mom went out
and bought for her that's honestly show
thought no it was so person it like she
we came in she was wearing a jumpsuit
we're like wow fabulous birthday and she
was like wait now I have this other
dress we're like no even better do that
and she was like look in the closet and
we open it and it's all white that dress
is so funny honestly that's that's
important no that is being in tune with
what's necessary anyways I mean I don't
know how much longer I can sit here
without talking about like the two major
things that happened this weekend won
the Game of Thrones finale which gave me
one second until I say number two James
Charles
tenshun video holy [ __ ] hi Geoffrey
star-like attempt at her no and here's
the thing James Charles put out his
video and I turned and I was like oh my
god James like this is what I were
talking about me I just wanna go back to
see it myself I think this is what I was
waiting for why'd you even bother with
that apology video when I turned out
that apology video cuz I wanted to hear
from you this was the video I needed and
then I was looking for and then when I
didn't get it I just went to Tottie's
and then she was the precious gem of a
woman so I just believed her then after
about st. Charles video I was like you
know what I'm not going back into
cancellation mode I want to see the
final video with receipts from Jeffrey
star and then I will make my decision
Jeffrey star released his video at 9
o'clock p.m. Eastern time when Game of
Thrones goes live my god so dumb so but
also we can definitely want people to
see it because it's suck it sucks and
you know what actually I need to calm
down because I don't limit like get on
Jeffery stars bad side and/or Chucky I
know and I'm feeling really seems like
he's done taking people down okay so who
are the Fast Five stories that you need
to know before you wake up and take a
bite out of your morning toast if that's
okay I guess we're starting with James
Charles okay I couldn't agree more and
I've been through like a really like a
big cycle of emotions through this whole
thing because you know like I've really
recently before this whole thing became
like a really big James Charles fan for
a lot of reasons and I just thought it
was like admirable that like this kid
who is really a kid like gets so much
hate for literally no reason for showing
up at the Met Gala literally the meanest
comments on his Instagram but I just
like I don't know I took a liking
towards him I liked I liked his videos
I've been subscribed him for a while I
like the sister squad and they took this
whole you know incident really to heart
and I guess I'm like such a fair-weather
bandwagon fan because like in the week
since this video has come out like I've
just been like investing in YouTube a
lot and I become like a huge jeffree
star fan subscribe to him watch his
videos like on all my long drives
throughout Israel on the back of the bus
you know the whole thing I have just
been really like out here just loving
Jeffrey star and like I knew he's a [ __ ]
start and I've read all the I read all
the stuff about him and Kylie like he
has a lot of drama with Kylie he's
always like honestly reviewing her
products whatever and now I'm just
really unsure because I had made up my
mind you know what I mean I made up my
mind but no here's what I'm sure of I'm
team James all the way first of all he
handled his cancellation like a pro and
it's like a person whose purse
invested in cancellations and what
people do with them I'm just I'm so
proud for for all of canceled culture
it's a big step because also he made
such a good point which is that like
this whole thing in this video like
brought him to such a dark place and all
of the comments and like we were all so
quick to judge and it doesn't matter no
one should ever have to feel that way
ever like but that was my problem which
every stars video he said you know in
this past week I've been in a dark place
I why it's not about you I think what he
meant as a dark place is like his evil
place where he's sending out evil tweets
and he's ready to put out evil and he
doesn't want to be that person you know
like now just allude to the fact that
like they have dark thoughts when they
get in trouble for stuff and they're
like it's it's supposed to like be an
excuse no I I think it was different our
crisis like I think James Charles like
without saying it was like depressed and
like thinking really scary thoughts
whereas Jeffrey star went to a place of
being like an evil youtuber which I
guess he used to be yeah and he doesn't
want to be that person now whether or
not that means he just like didn't have
the receipts to back it up or he really
has turned a corner in his life it
doesn't matter like James Charles has
come on top now now I'm watching the
live sub count meet you oh my god and I
never I guess I talked to big talk about
going to subscribe I'm subscribing and
subscribing I never did anything so I
don't have to undo anything um but I'm
so happy for him I wish he never put out
that apology video well so he had to
contain and I don't think and that's
what this whole thing is has come to
it's like nobody thought it would turn
into the big shitstorm that it did so
when James released that video I'm sure
he was like I just have to do this and
like we'll move on from it but it
literally never ended like enews
BuzzFeed like real legit publications
would not stop writing it up every time
someone did something and James's video
was was perfect for a lot of reasons one
it's like you can't argue with proof so
it's like he had no shortage of proof
I'm like Mike I don't if I wanted to go
back and find a text message like I
can't do that he literally had so much
you could see some of them were from his
computer some of them were for his phone
like he really did his due diligence and
God did his research and like made sure
that every I was dotted and every T was
crossed and that's what I wanted from
Jeffrey cuz I'm like there's no way that
I could believe takis video so
wholeheartedly and then also believe
James is so I'm like there must be more
because I'm
we've talked to you so much but also
James even though they're so conflicting
so I'm like what what am I missing and
now they're like what you're missing we
can't reveal like okay nothing says I
haven't uh proofs like a 13 minute video
that says absolutely nothing right also
I think the most person part of James's
video like the most effective was the
Swift takedown of zara larsson
holy [ __ ] like not only was it like the
clap act of all time but it was so true
what he said about his private DM to her
boyfriend versus the way that she
courted him in the first place and the
way that we talk about each of them just
based on their gender and sexuality no
Jackie totally and what's so shocking is
how many people since since this whole
thing happened so many people came out
and like had stories about and literally
every single person has retracted what
they said so zara larsson apologized on
Twitter
I don't Instagram again this morning and
that random person who went viral saying
it was a social experiment that Jam
that's all literally that is evil like
that person is truly like an evil person
100% but like but they at least it's
like a 300 a did a horrible social
experiment but at least give us the
results right like they did a harm it
was an interesting result there wasn't
it like and everyone and us included
because like we even sat here and like
tried to see both sides and like worried
debate about James Charles's mental
health just because we just assumed
everything that Tati said was completely
factual but nobody we're all like and I
think there was a lot that she said that
was true and I think a lot of that would
definitely got too big for you God use
me for his britches forgot where he came
from definitely acted like a celebrity
etc and he apologized that for that at
the end of his video he was like about
all that like that's true and Ana and I
need to work on that the famous thing
was so interesting and it was really the
perfect the only it was the only
response that would have made sense do
you don't even like I thought that was
one then the screenshots of his
Instagram is having Kylie and Lauren
gray like I loved all of that I loved it
and I guess that's what everyone says so
like we're so famous no totally I'm
gonna start using that now but I want to
talk about the Sarah Larson oh and so
now a lot of the speculation is like
it's very odd cuz everyone who came out
against in Zara Larsson that ran the
person from Twitter Tati James has
apologized and it's like we want to drop
it talk to you deleted her video like
people are like I sister yeah so people
are like oh it's literally like
everyone's just bitching out I was like
Jay
definitely threaten legal action some
timeles has sent them a cease and desist
for defamation I have like I don't know
have any proof but I'm 100% certain that
it's just so not the truth because if
that were the case and they were all
scared straight by a lawyer they would
not they would stop making videos they
all keep making more videos no also if
he was threatening defamation if what
Tati said is true then she could back it
up it in court and it wouldn't be
defamatory if it's the truth and they
would say we can't talk about this
because James has certain legal action
you could say that sorry talk to this
video isn't elite that it's now unlisted
so if you have the link you can watch it
but you if you search by sister it won't
come up interesting yeah well I'm just
I'm so impressed by James Charles I
can't even tell you and like I was
turned and he brought me back from the
brink no 1,000% and the numbers
fluctuating is like interesting to watch
but it's also so sad cuz it's like these
are people who are like huge YouTube
fans and like so easily they can be like
I mean honestly me to them oh but it was
so it was also persuasive
yeah it was really except for Jeffrey's
Tati
Jeffrey tweets etc was really like so
coordinated almost and I think that's
what James was alluding to in his video
but he doesn't have proof so he didn't
say but like the way that Jeffrey like
texted him and said what's coming out
like what's gonna happen it was like a
threatened like a whole symphony of a
takedown in text messages I don't it
didn't come out of nowhere those text
messages were evil like calling him a
predator and I can really glad that they
heard from that waiter guy cuz he was
like first of all he's an [ __ ]
illegally recording a FaceTime
conversation I didn't watch his video
but he knew that James told me
everything I need to know that's what I
needed to know the guy went there on his
own and consented to kissing him like
literally how can you call James Charles
a predator when he just invited someone
over right and then also that they had
multiple conversations about his
sexuality which is why James had text
messages sent to him that were about his
sexuality he wasn't trying to convince
him right no the guy was like seeking
out him am i straight and he was like
you're definitely not totally straight
and you know what I love that James used
that clip from Jane from Jeffrey about
like being a gay man who's into straight
men because I never understood that
concept before and first of all was just
Shady of him to use that video but also
it was quite helpful and explanatory
occasionally an evening Jane said like I
love this clip from Jeffrey and that's
what's so interesting about all of these
videos it's like they all start with
I respect I love I admire you know I
just kindness in my heart and you know
and I like I love our relationship and
now I'm gonna annihilate you yeah and
then at the end like I just hope we can
come back from this it's all very pretty
it's all very pretty and there's
something like in the water in the
beauty YouTube community but then also
at the end of the day this has been
major for the YouTube beauty community
this is the major for YouTube yeah this
has been major for James jeffree star
and Tati and like I'd like to think they
were all smart enough to put this on
however like the way where it took James
to definitely that was not never gonna
be a place like I don't think it was all
orchestrated but the way it all came out
it's like everyone got more subscribers
than they started with business is
booming oh my bear hair thing I just
want to talk about it
oh me too that's what I was gonna say
because in my IMO James really didn't do
anything wrong like okay no [ __ ] should
he have not I don't even know it's like
okay every text message that he sent to
top he was like hey so long he made it
seem he was unreachable brief doesn't
give a [ __ ]
posted told her after etc but no he was
like so inept he felt so horrible the
only thing I'll say is like the being
mauled and unsafe and VIP at Coachella
is a reach definitely it's a lot of
pictures and stuff for him but we were
at Coachella we were fine but like I
thought gigi hadid
and the darkness passes I'm just saying
but she's was sitting on the ground with
her friends but I think also the way
that she like I think James Charles is
more approachable for a photo than Gigi
Hadid like she's more of a submarine
like because he is a social media
celebrity like people feel like they
know him and that's what makes him like
that makes him so loveable but it also
causes a scene ya know I mean there are
a lot of famous people are Coachella
James Charles is by no means the most
famous one I do think he just wanted an
artist passed for like the cloud of it
which is fine so did wait like there's
nothing to be shameful about that but
lying and saying like I felt unsafe like
are you kidding me lately no one was
gonna harm you it's just a lot I think I
think it was annoying and it's
definitely like hindering your good time
but when he went through the whole sugar
bear heard him at all like I was turn
okay and then also then like it's oh and
then the most interesting part is Nikita
dragon was in this week's episode of
four houses in Beverly Hills she was a
Turkish oh oh my god
I was so I'm like I'm at full circle
YouTube moment wow I didn't even realize
that and we we have to talk about all
the te have you been watching team I
caught up on New York Beverly Hills and
southern charm on the plane oh
absolutely such a productive 24 hours no
that's really great this morning okay so
I had one more thing to say about the
drama of it all but at the end of the
day I'm a bigger James Charles fan than
when I started I [ __ ] Stan I'm
Stannis Baratheon 3 James Charles and
I'm proud of him no me too what a video
that's how it's done ladies and gents I
couldn't agree more
I'm gonna miss him while he's gone cuz I
really love his makeup videos but here's
what I was saying is that we could all
this is a this was really a social
experiment for society and how cancel
culture can be so damaging and people
just like say like I think the craziest
part of this whole thing is that that
one person who tweeted a crazy
allegation about him in high school was
a complete fabrication like literally
pulled out of thin air like that in my
opinion is the worse than anything any
of these people did like that is [ __ ]
evil and that person like should be
truly ashamed of themselves
agreed so now here's my question where
do we go from here in terms of we all
behaved horrendously during this entire
saga how do we do it differently next
time you both and I feel like this
happens every time even with Jordan wood
he's all piled on and we watch
read.table and we're like oh my god
we're terrible people
and so say this happened again like what
it's all we and James Charles said like
everyone is just guilty until proven
innocent yeah but when he made I think
it was really that apology video that he
made just confirmed everything that Todd
had said so I just assumed talked to his
right James is apologizing we're moving
on but you know what I did like that he
he I think he knows that people feel
that way because the first thing he did
he said I stand by that video like I am
sorry I do love to talk to you like I
got emotional because like these are my
family on but there's more to the story
so like at least he didn't close over
the fact that he like totally pussied
out in that video yes so I think next
time we just need it's so hard but we
just need to wait it out I'm not
speaking on anything until I put it we
had heard from both sides I don't know
how we could have done differently
that's the problem I don't know what
lesson there is here other than one
don't believe every tweet from someone
in high school animated zara larsson
like doesn't know everything but oh then
you know what here's the lesson and it's
a lesson that Chrissy Teigen tweeted
four years ago when Logan Paul was
getting canceled for his
actually title forest video yeah I think
it's two years ago it was such a good
point she was like why can't we just
start disliking people and like unfollow
them in silence like why do we always
have to make it like a hashtag or make
it like an actual thing to cancel this
person like can we all just move on from
this person and like move on with our
lives and focus on better more positive
things like you don't have to love
everyone and if someone does something
that you admire and it upsets you like
great move on like you don't have to
make it a party no I agreed you have to
throw a party I agree I think it was a
wise thing that Chrissy Teigan thought
it was it's quite pertinent to this
situation okay we'll keep you it sounds
like everyone's going dark now so
there's not much to keep you updated on
and Wow it's gonna be a quiet couple of
weeks in the beauty community yeah I
mean this would be a good time for like
you know Jacqueline Hill video she just
launched her cosmetics line and it's so
funny now I'm like so invested in
YouTube in them in the morning tube
which is the morning toaster is a
YouTube subgroup and she finally
launched it apparently she's been saying
she's gonna launch her makeup line for
eight years and people in the comments
were like even her biggest fans they're
like honestly I don't care like she said
for eight years ago was when she started
that she was gonna she kept saying next
year I wonder what happened I mean it's
hard to launch a brand we know we're
launching a multi-faceted Brad a
multimedia Brad we're gonna camp toes
this weekend hey hey I can't believe
this is you can its here I can't believe
it was a weather holds it would just
like make it incredible yeah I'm excited
I'm a little nervous like to make some
new camp friends you know I know I just
got on my I just ordered my bedding I
just packed all my scent bird oh you did
yeah oh crap I have to do that yeah oh
but I and I haven't packed for this camp
yeah yeah but I gotta pack my sunburn
I don't know stir think I'm smelling
yeah it could be hot it's like a lot of
hugging lots of pictures I got I need
someone giving me a hug and like
smelling my like sweaty hair you know
right Sanford is an absolute necessity
for camp toasts and all other events
especially this summer
have you ever had someone come up to you
and say you smell amazing what perfume
you're wearing
well I have him but Sanford is a luxury
fragrance subscription service for
perfumes and colognes it's a way for you
to just stop to discover new perfumes
and colognes without buying an entire
bottle your toots are more than four
hundred and fifty designer brands of a
perfumer Cologne each month Prada Tom
Ford Versace Dolce & Gabbana rich you
choose a perfume you want to try in the
Ascend you a 30 day supply that's 120
sprays enough to apply more than four
times daily for a month and with our
exclusive offer you can get 50% off your
first month today that's only seven
dollars and fifty cents for your first
fragrance go to Sandburg
/ toast and use our code toast for 50%
off your first month again that's sent
bird SC ENT bir d.com / toast and use
our code toast for 50% off your first
month
that's your first perfume or cologne for
just seven dollars and fifty cents
sign-on smell amazing yeah I got a pack
also someone made a good point about
Jaclyn hill logan brown said she was
waiting to get divorced so her husband
didn't have ownership Wow interesting
it's like you actors do you shoot
community is just it's mind boggling
I feel like I've really been missing out
on it I know and now you know I so i
have like youtube TV and they use all
these apps and i watched all the james
Charles videos like on my YouTube app on
my TV and then I was just like watching
other videos and I think like now I mean
I guess this is what YouTube wants but
like to really just like watch YouTube
like its TV you know and in this whole
thing I really found myself just
watching more tutorials and I have made
no matter if you notice just took a
couple changes to my routine because you
know Jeffrey star really taught me the
most important thing is a primer and I
was just using some like shitty NYX
primer I use a spray primer no like he
they could which one is that
I forget what when he said was the best
one but I'm going to invest in a good
primer and also changed foundations I
found that they could it cosmetics CC
cream was a little too full coverage for
me I'm now back on to my Giorgio Armani
and luminous silk foundation which
Jeffrey star says is one of the best oh
I love the NARS foundation I need full
coverage because go please um okay that
was only one story that I mean though
there's two big stories today and the
other three actually our process was
pretty big second story Game of Thrones
finale last night 8 years for me
personally waiting ten years for some
people most people probably like one
year bonis but it happened and this is
what I have to say everyone big ol
thumbs down and everyone is disappointed
except for me what I thought it was the
way but it was buttoned up like maybe
it's not the way I would have done it in
my dream world you know Danny and John
world together having Leto incestual
babies and everyone the Starks in
Winterfell it's the Seven Kingdoms of
course I would love that we always knew
it wasn't gonna be a happy ending so
with that in mind it was a pretty happy
ending I thought it was a happy ending
I'm not mad this is what I was saying to
Ben I'm like I'm not mad at all that it
came full circle we tied up a lot of
sounds like I likes that an engine like
a Disney Channel show kind of way like
not everyone's happy but like there's
peace in the realm I liked that but how
we got there made literally no sense
like what was the point in all this John
drama being a Targaryen having what we
could if we never would have found out
she would have been the same except him
being a Targaryen and the rightful heir
maybe didn't crazy contributed to her
badness what I did like that they did I
never liked as much as I wanted him to
sit on the throne and I think I
predicted last week that that would have
been like my ending I never thought he
was fit for the throne first of all he's
he died so like I don't think that like
he was brought back to you know help
build this new world like that was his
role and to help kill the night king but
I don't think a dead person sits like
someone on their second life would sit
on the throne I don't know it was just
like that to me it's like as much as I
stand him and like I loved him and he
really was the rightful heir to the
throne the more I got to see if him I'm
like he would make a terrible leader
like sometimes the hard decision is not
the right the right decision is the hard
decision and like he could not be
bothered to make any sort of decision
like he knew Jennie was terrible but
he's still like I said love feels duty
like shut the [ __ ] up like so being a
good Miller is knowing what's right and
knowing how to move forward and he was
such a goddamn [ __ ] I don't think I
didn't want him to be the ruler I think
he would have been a good ruler he's
always made hard decisions like when he
had to go make peace with the wildlings
and unite them like who else could have
done that however my season eight Jon
would never have done that like season 1
jon was such a man supposed to go his
season 7 he went down to Daenerys to get
the dragon stone and he held his own up
until she went above the wall and lost a
dragon for him and that's when she
decided she was his queening you know
what we were all there when they were
holding hands my queen when she was
talking to me to the unsullied and the
Dothraki about taking Winterfell like I
was like this [ __ ] has gotta go but you
know what I love days like the way she
went mad it's like when she was making
her speech she was a VC know like
power-hungry but when she was talking to
John it was like she wasn't such a far
cry from the girl she was two episodes
before no and like she's making sense
but what John was saying is like well
everyone thinks so doing the righteous
thing even evil people so it's like
you're technically saying like evil
things and you're just saying that
you're liberating people but you're
really just killing them right so it was
like it wasn't like she became this
person
couldn't understand it was like she was
just felt so right about what she was
doing that she couldn't see that maybe
she was wrong
the episode was stitched together in a
weird way where the second something
finally happened a case further alert
John killed Danny which was just
beautiful and poetic but really sad when
the dragon like had to pick her up on
her corpse and carry her to this weird
like a council meeting like a month
later I would presume yeah and it makes
no sense because first of all what
happened in that month I just
anarchy like where who's ruling the
people yeah I'm sure it was an arc he
was like this until he sees John
everyone was like come down we gotta get
a new ruler I'm sure with hanneke I
didn't want to watch it I was glad that
we got the one month later I think we
got one month worth of beard I'm kid and
an extra month worth of beard Ontarian I
think the reason why people were so
disappointed is because there isn't one
person who I thought should be king or
queen like when they were picking from
that list of people and her uncle stood
up I'm like you know fine he'd be good
like I wasn't mad even more of the same
yeah but you know what I'm saying it's
like I wasn't like riding or dying for
anyone because everyone I loved to
either died or went crazy so it's like
there was never gonna be a happy ending
for anyone because there was no good
choice but I actually think that brand
even though everyone was like he does
nothing else ease in and he you know
gets it put his name on the group
project I think really he is he is a
good king first of all he could see
everything no one can conspire against
him he's the king he ate he's not the
king we want he's his own like master of
whisperers you know what really got in
me you want to know let me think
yeah okay when they were sitting around
with the small council and they're
really like they're talking about you
know sewage systems and rebuilding and
really boring governmental things that
like that's what the small council
should be doing and it's like no one
would have loved that more than Marys Oh
justice for Barris was never [ __ ]
served it was though because he served
the realm and the realm is in an okay
place maybe he's looking down he's proud
of how everything happened unfortunately
he's not there to enjoy it that would
like hurt for me he would have been a
wonderful seat at that table you know
who I feel like I really didn't want to
be sitting there is [ __ ] Bron
because he's a traitorous little [ __ ]
and now he's like the richest man in the
realms but I don't give a [ __ ] he's evil
he's not a good guy yeah he was
definitely when when tyrion found
jaime and cersei which by the way is
just like so far-fetched so you would
find two corpses and like a city
completely burned alive and like their
corpses were completely fine like they
looked like they were just sleeping that
was very sweet and quite sad no one
liked the way that they died and this is
also what's crazy the way that he died
was like so sweet and I guess if I had
to choose like maybe like ideals just
like a bricks in the head but what's
crazy is the to really like epic love
sagas that culminate in the end are
Cersei and Jaime and Jon and Daenerys so
it's like love his incestual love and
maybe that's the message family over
everything
maybe this message and like at the end
it's we have no love stories you know
Sansa's queen of the north you in the
beginning of the season you were fully
convinced that everyone was gonna die
with a lover or like a ha end with a
yeah or even when Sansa was like walking
down with her you know dress and of
course you know I guess it's like the
patriarchy and me just I was assuming
she was getting married oh I think she's
banging Tyrion and yes and I was like so
excited when he sat when Tyrion was like
everyone loves the story I was like a
love story Sansa will you marry me I
really thought that they were gonna end
up together like big like romantic
gesture was a proposal in front of
everyone no and then that would bridge
the north to the six kingdoms and you
know and keep it I mean they'll always
have the bridge because there's both
Starks in both places but then also
would have been like at the beginning
how Jon Arryn was the hand of the king
and Lysa was living elsewhere like Sansa
could have stayed in the north while her
husband was the hand in the south yeah
and now it's like there's an or there's
a stark above the wall there's a stark
in the north as a shark so the structure
thought that the way that Jon story
ended like made so much sense first of a
horrible he is a crow till the end he
and looking highborn and now what the
hell is it a do beyond the wall now no
but hey hey freedom he's like that's the
only way he could be free so it's
because he can't say in Kingsland well
because unsullied and I said last week
that there gonna be a problem
yeah like how are we gonna their army
was just like so blood hungry worm was
like such a little [ __ ] like a little he
lost he and he had he lost his love he
lost his queen he had nothing to live
for other than to ruin there was just so
many things that happened in the first
aid season that you thought would be in
hoarding that literally ended up like
not mattering whatsoever like what that
what was the [ __ ] was the point in the
girl with no face
um one Walter Frank cheated that to
Benson but it's like okay well her
killing Walder Frey was like a nice
revenge thing for her it wasn't integral
no it wasn't integral but it was a nicer
venting and learning how to be an
assassin and being sneaking like a cat
to kill the night kid she was like I'm
not coming with you I was like finally
she's gonna go to Gendry
I thought she was gonna go to Braavos
when I was like she was done I thought
she was gonna go back to the east to
like be an assassin but she's done like
it's so like and there was also just a
bunch of things not only that didn't
make sense but like that didn't end like
where's the dragon the dragon oh yeah he
flew East like okay where brands gonna
find him totally oh yeah I thought at
that meeting he was fully gonna like
rolls eyes - had been like I said [ __ ]
that
so maybe so many memes that were like
drogon burned the Iron Throne because he
knew brand already had a chair mean no
but that's just like he was he's
practical he was practical - the burning
of the throne was just epic
it being it hurt though cuz it was like
who's gonna sit on the iron but it was a
metaphor cuz like he was trying to kill
the person who killed Denny which would
make you think he'll kill Jon but no it
was really the throne that killed her oh
my god she lost her goddamn mind
she lost her goddamn mind she was her
[ __ ] eyebrows were going nuts when
she was talking to Jon and I didn't see
I didn't see that coming and killing her
because he's such a [ __ ] I didn't get
was actually gonna do anything also
think something I didn't make a total
lot of sense means everyone like keep
saying that the long winter is coming
and like yes of course it also means the
White Walkers which had been defeated
but it's like [ __ ] freezing and and
how are they gonna survive beyond the
wall for like now we have 10 years of
winter well so I totally thought like as
the episode I was waiting for [ __ ]
something I'm like as their episodes
ending there's a white Walker like I'm
like give me something right I thought
there would be something just like so
that it can pose a question the kind of
how um shutter island' ends or whatever
one of those movies where it's like do
you believe he is the prisoner is he not
it's like now we can for years to come
talk about what we think happened with
that one white Walker who was left
yeah I'm sure John just killed him I
thought here's what I thought was gonna
happen when the dragon huh Daenerys is
corpse like she's becoming the night
Queen oh my god
no our or I thought that like John have
gotten away with it how would they they
Danny would have disappeared how did
they know
that it was him they must have turn
himself in because cuz he's such a [ __ ]
because he's annoying oh my god he
doesn't know how to lie remember when he
couldn't lie to Cersei no remember when
he she Cersei said that she would bring
her armies if when I'm done fighting the
dead if John would not pledge allegiance
to anyone he was like don't lose my
queen he's and she was like loser II was
like that was really sweet but you
couldn't just lie you know it was just
really interesting who at the end like
who mattered because we've been through
so many characters in the past in the
first eight seasons and like we thought
Ned Stark was important he wasn't but
it's like at the end of the day it's
like I love her but like bran of Tarth
like sitting it like she made it she is
head of the Kingsguard good for her and
like a great feminist moment but the
memes about what she was booked I'm so
funny I suggest someone commented that
she was ready to see me sweetheart
funny and it was like sweet that she
liked cuz the whole time it was like he
didn't do anything cuz they'll always be
known as a Kingslayer and it was like a
sweet like a nice ass way to like close
the book yeah I knew before they showed
us I thought to myself he died
protecting his Queen yeah and it was
that would make no sense because like
Brienne was in love with him and like he
she would never write something nice
know she was in love like I think that
she would she's the bigger woman but
it's literally like she was supposed to
end up with tormund and like that was
just totally glazed over I just feel
like maybe we need to set her up a
profiling like OkCupid
like the app and just like get to get to
work because what I've heard is really
premium about OkCupid it's the only
dating app that finds you someone based
on who you are and what you're into it's
like who would we get for Braniff start
someone who's like into physical combat
obviously maybe Bronn someone who's like
type is like a bigger woman when it
comes to dating you know exactly what
you like the OkCupid dating app has tons
of fun questions about the things you
care about and it's your own answers
that lead to fascinating conversations
and even better dates it's so simple you
match with someone on what really
matters to you based on the answers to
your questions like they have a tight
range of questions they let me ask you
like what do you think about like Russia
you know like something like that or
something as simple as like do you pay
extra for guac you know the things
that's more important to me than Russia
so they okay keep it up it finds you
someone based on who you are what you're
into you check it out go to the OkCupid
app available and all the app store
Premium if you find someone like we get
credit for it right
I hope so marry someone you met on oh
yeah but yeah I think we'll get great
credit in the eyes of the seven yeah
right the old ever knew
yeah the old got down the nail yeah and
it's at the end of the day which gods
prevailed you know cuz it was a really a
battle and all so where does the Lord of
Light coming to everything we never not
just as sick was it real I mean I guess
it was real like she proved that and the
Lord of Light was really like there to
take down the night king he doesn't care
about who said something Iron Throne
right it's like it doesn't even matter
that all the people are dead so who
cares yeah oh but it was interesting to
see actually like I've heard that there
are seven kingdoms but like I couldn't
name them and then when I saw all the
people sitting there I go hey Dorne it
Winterfell horn Winterfell King's
Landing uh King's Landing the reach live
which is Highgarden then the Vale
Lannisport and oh we have to talk about
Robin Arryn oh he's hot he's high
there's about him were so funny took me
a few beats to like put it together I
didn't even realize it was him until I
saw it on Twitter okay so now let's play
a fun game where it's like of course
everyone has to get married and bear
children eventually even except for
Brandon whenever you see the memes or
it's like no one yeah how are we pairing
people but I know they're cousins but
like I actually feel like a union
between Robin Arryn and Sansa would be
like so power but he's nuts but and the
North doesn't do that he look nuts
his mom finally died and he was cooled
down and he grew who know he like is
definitely not OK from breastfed till he
was eight brave but he like looks good
he's good on the outside but definitely
not on the inside there's really like no
this this is such a relatable problem
like there are no good guys out there
for sons she needs to she's OkCupid you
know I but I really ship still likes
onsen Gendry and it's like if aria is
never coming back like can't they just
get together yeah I don't understand
like aria is purpose in this world
because I thought it was like to get
justice for her family and like she had
the opportunity she was like I came here
to kill Cersei but someone Danny got
here for something actually no you got
there first and you could have done it
so it's like I thought her machine in
life was like to kill all the people who
and like a venture family she had the
opportunity she did it so then I thought
I'm like oh this is like a love story
for her in kendry she had the
opportunity she did it so
when she has the opportunity to do
whatever she wants to it gets on a boat
and goes to nowhere I think it's all
about her just wanting to do whatever
she wants because when she's a kid she
was a kid and think she was like I'm not
a lady she never said what she was I
think she wants me a knight at one point
but like she just wanted option yeah she
just want to stick to the the paycheck
she just wanted to be able to do
whatever she felt like doing and you
know what I guess they can respect that
now
samwell's Oates a mild Harley he's with
Gilley he's spoken for he's he's spoken
for he left a plastic water bottle on
set and he's getting roasted on Twitter
as well
it's so janky and it's so unfair people
are like they'd be like rushed in this
season like there's water bottle these
are not rushing this season the the
level of production like that's not
there for you to like say they rush
through the season because there's a
water bottle and now everyone should go
through all the other seasons I'm sure
there's so many inconsistencies you just
want to find problems with seasoning
because you're a hater yeah I mean if
you watch friends the inconsistencies
are so crazy and so obvious like to
another level that I can't believe like
it that show actually came from like a
legitimate like production studio
because it's a joke right someone just
said honestly the funniest tweet I saw
was like tormund and Robin Arryn really
making the case for breastfeeding for a
reasonable amount of time no totally
tormund and when when John was going
back up to the wall I was like [ __ ]
depressed I'm like this sucks
and then I saw I liked where mine's
little redhead and I was like maybe John
isn't is north three went through and
when John was like maybe gonna be king
still before it was brand I was like
John and Kings landings just not working
for me yeah he like couldn't change his
clothes he's like couldn't wear his wolf
on his neck yeah and that's seen when
they were all just like saying by the
John they were all just like repeating
lines from the first episode you know
it's like we get it it's full circle
like you know have to make it so so like
obvious ya know I can't believe the
show's over I'm NACO am I like it is a
huge burden off my shoulders like there
were six episodes I was home and ready
to watch for one of them like my life is
just not built for like watching a TV
show on time and one that you can't like
get spoiled if you don't watch a second
that it starts so it's like I'm so fine
with the show being over like peace out
[ __ ]
like you did me dirty and I'm done did
not do me dirty and here's the other
thing even though things didn't happen
the way we all would have liked and some
character development skidding pan out
in your preferential way I
feel like I have any question marks like
I feel good I feel like all those sons
were tied there's no like remaining
questions or like this doesn't like so
even if it didn't work out the way you
wanted it to everything really worked
out and I was worried that I would have
all these lingering like you know just
what about this what about that but they
really just tied it up so nicely and
that was my biggest concern that I would
that I wouldn't be able to move past but
I feel like so satisfied yeah I didn't
think that I would that was my concern
what's funny is that of all the like the
proposed theories nobody ever thought
that brand was gonna end up being the
king but now if you think about it like
we could never figure out like what was
so important about the three-eyed Raven
and like what brands [ __ ] purpose was
cuz he was sticking around like putting
his eyes upon his head like we could
never figure it out now you got a
helpful sometimes right but it makes so
much sense but like he was self-serving
like when he found out that John was a
Targaryen like he told everyone knowing
that it would make Denny crazy to clear
room for him in his wheelchair to get on
the throne you know so I'm not okay so
it's in you or Brandon like maybe that
was technically self-serving except I I
mean it's it's easy to think that it was
now but he has this information about
John of course of shooting I have told
him no he totally should have best to
keep Danny from not going that if she's
so [ __ ] delicate what is that well
it's a letdown it does make sense
bran because yeah I've never figured out
like what the [ __ ] is purpose was why
did the night king want him so much and
what the hell is a three-eyed Raven I
mean knowing I'm like how can it serve
but know it and what do you think I came
here for yeah our [ __ ]
no I'm honestly I really was here for it
like he'd no one came to try him he can
see everything he thoroughly understands
the past and that's what's most
important for the future which is why I
was a history major maybe I should sit
on the throne are you the three-eyed
Raven show me how you put your eyes
behind your head
I can't do it like you can wait am i
doing it yeah and also the fact that he
has no personal ties he doesn't identify
his brand stark it helps because he's
not going to be biased in any way it
really is an impartial leader who's
well-versed in history
the Seven Keys starting to look a lot
like the og three-eyed Raven and the og
three-eyed Raven lived for like a
thousand years to me we don't have to
decide on a new ruler anytime soon right
it was a vegetarian is a good idea and
you know what stories really are what
unites people like literally me and my
friends all we do is when we hang out is
to talk about stories from college and
like yeah that's a deal of like a a back
story you know like a triumphant moment
and I think all throughout the eight
seasons they were like and barres loves
to say power sides where men think of
resides but is it armies is it gold no
maybe it really is stories is what
unites people and I think that that's a
nice message and that's what we do I'm
the Shelby tell stories so here we are
uniting people and that was our second
story of the day
I can't believe only a second one so
much it happened this week I know and I
had one more thought but I guess I'm
gonna have to let it go well we're
officially closing the chapter on Game
of Thrones I hope you've enjoyed our
recaps somewhat famous recaps I would
say people all around the world have
told us that their husbands only listen
to the show when we talk about Game of
Thrones so I will miss that but you know
what like I'm ready for the world to
move on to something new you're being
you're being too harsh no I'm a little
more invested in the James Charles of it
all okay so what would have been your
ideal ending that's what I'm saying I
don't have an idea there was no one I
was championing so I was only let down
because like bran is such a weirdo but
it does make sense so like I respect the
thought behind him being chosen but like
I don't know if all like the epic
moments on the show you just expected
the end to be had one of those epic
moments with Jon killing Danny was epic
um like it should have been but like
John was pissing me off like honestly I
wanted him dead more than I wanted her
to I thought he was gonna not kill her
in that moment and then have to kill her
later on I didn't think I was gonna be
so good you know it was just it was fun
okay you're a tough critic Mike I mean
the whole world is a tough critic like
yeah there was nothing they could have
done that would have made us love it
because the reason why the show was so
epic is before anyone cared about it
like they were killing off people
laughing yeah and like there was no
expectation now it has branded itself as
the most you know unexpected amazing
crazy show and there was literally
nothing they could have done that what
if a made sense and blown our minds yeah
they wanted to make sense
okay so George Martin has Texas people
are really hating on the writers for
this ending but he said that the ending
to the
isn't gonna be much different other than
like secondary characters might have a
different story um but I think that
means that brand ends up on the chair no
there's no throne anymore okay I mean I
can't promise it I'm never gonna talk
about Game of Thrones again in this
episode or ever again because it's just
completely its iconic it's just Tom
shrined
and it's really historic the biggest TV
show that's ever been and maybe ever
will be true
I wonder what's gonna be next it's just
I feel like the one before this was like
Breaking Bad like when the whole world
was on its feet like ready to watch the
finale you know not really of this
magnitude but um I do wonder what will
be just as well maybe it's Real
Housewives of Beverly Hills maybe it may
be tough NL maybe it's us melt because
Scarlett Johansson and Colin Jost are
engaged actress Scarlett Johansson and
SNL co-head writer Colin Jost are
getting hitched Johansson's publicist
confirmed on Sunday that the couple is
engaged but has not yet set a date
Johansson and Jose first made headlines
after page six exclusively reported that
ScarJo who was going through a divorce
at the time was spotting kissing was
spotted kissing Jost after her
appearance on SNL sweet scar Scarlett
just Hansen if that's not her like hash
tag or something I'll be really
disappointed even though like he's a
comedy writer like maybe you could come
up with something a little bit better um
I'm really excited for them I'm I can't
leave I only been dating for two years
because like we've only been doing the
show for two years and I feel like we'd
like been talking about like Colin Jost
like being the one hour a week worker
like forever right I like them I think
they're really sweet I think
I love how low-key they are it's like oh
I barely believed they were dating for
so long because we never like saw
anything um um and now they're engaged
like that sounds like the real deal to
me and I just I mean I have a lot of
repellant just ever since I saw him in a
little black t-shirt at the end of one
of the SNL episodes and like I've never
seen someone like bulging out of a
t-shirt more than he was so honestly
here forever no he's always like
impressing me when it's like I'm so hard
on him no we just have like really low
expectations for Colin Jost cuz he only
works one hour a week and by the way
like we know that he doesn't work when I
were weak like don't get your patacas in
the twist
um he's we just have low expectations
for his luck Andy Jamie does something
like kind of funny or like cute we're
like oh my god call it and they know we
were really worried at the beginning of
their relationship because he only works
when I were weak you know he's home
he's probably knowing he's gonna be like
a stay-at-home dad right but I'm glad
they were able to work through that and
like figure out a schedule that works
for them yeah like now I was telling her
so like I think I'll be gone like a
little bit more is he going into work um
I actually maybe it's Michael che I've
get them confused like because they both
have the same job when are we and
mediocre Instagram said like I come
across every now and then Oh got it
where they announce their tours it's
being at my tour I had to go with a job
back home to get tickets I'm heading to
Lexington Kentucky Minneapolis sorry I
sold out a lot of the shows are sold out
we added some more but there's tickets
available at girl tone job com2 some of
them so I can't wait to see the summer
speaking of self-promotion my presets
are available at Jackie O flow calm and
people are eleven times people are
loving them have you been looking at the
hash tagging well I see yes where were
you yeah sharing them it's just been so
positive so wonderful and I'm so glad
everyone loves them as much as I do and
we're just brighten up Instagram one one
day at a time you're revolutionised in
the field I've done so many comments
that people are just like so glad that
I'm you know really turning around like
the whole washout orange photos trend I
couldn't agree more and and we're here
for lightness and brightness and and
summer is here winter was coming
lightness and brightness oh my right
exactly
to give you seven news rails I did but I
told you I only had the indoor pack
maybe I gave you the code I know and you
know I was just like I got busy I'm
sorry I'm gonna do it that's not nice
I'm sorry I'm sorry I'm sorry I'm sorry
I'm sorry well you in action Oh what do
you have pictures that you still need to
post it was that TPG TBG UK came with us
Nicki and Oh a set photographer and he
edited them all behind survived I saw
that so he sent me the pictures already
edited so I wasn't gonna have any so you
can't they wouldn't fit that's what it
was yeah okay I understand it was I saw
the vibe and I was like okay I guess
that is like an Israeli it's a
particularly Middle Eastern shucky vibe
yeah shucky for sure okay Hugh are you
shook next story Claudia just sent to me
so I haven't had a chance to read it so
I want to read it because it looks
[ __ ] wild wild BuzzFeed news has put
out a report it's a huge expose leaked
records revealed tony robbins berated
abuse victims and former followers
accuse him of sexual advances okay geez
that's like such a letdown if it's true
you know let me get through a couple
paragraphs
20 robbins claims he has helped millions
of fans overcome some of life's darkest
difficulties but lease records reveal he
has used his fame
great victims of rape and violence while
former while female former staffers and
followers have accused him of
inappropriate sexual advances when Tony
Robbins leaps onstage in arenas around
the world under strobe lights and
pulsing speakers he's greeted by
thousands of screaming fans they clap
with him jump with him and when he puffs
his chest and lets out a primal roar
they were with him too
the world's most famous self-help guru
whips crowds into fits of euphoria a few
pop stars could dream of but many of his
fans are grappling with life's most
serious problems victims of sexual and
physical abuse along with people who
struggle with addiction and have mental
illnesses pay thousands of dollars to
see him on the promise he has the power
to quote transform your life and quote
rewire your brain at the court of
Robbins his teachings is the message
that his followers should not see
themselves as victims and should instead
view their pain as something they have
the power to quote destroy he claims so
revolutionized millions of lives with
this philosophy while building a
multi-billion dollar business and
working with celebrities from Donald
Trump and Bill Clinton to Oprah and the
Kardashians
access to his most exclusive membership
program has cost as much as eighty five
thousand dollars a year but behind the
dazzling veneer Robins guards his empire
with intense secrecy employees are bound
by strict confidentiality agreements and
audiences who attend his multi-day
coaching camps in the Sun contracts
forbidding them from recording what goes
on inside a year-long investigation by
BuzzFeed news based on linked recordings
internal documents and dozens of
interviews with fans and insiders
reveals how Robbins has berated abuse
victims and subjected his followers to
unorthodox and potentially dangerous
techniques and former female fans and
staffers have accused him of
inappropriate sexual advances to former
followers who went on to work for
Robbins provided BuzzFeed news with
signed statements swearing under oath
that they felt he had sexually harassed
them by repeatedly pursuing them after
they made clear they weren't interested
to more women who worked as his
assistant said Robbins expected them to
work alone with him when he was naked in
his hotel room or in the shower and
another former employee said she was
fired after having a consensual sexual
relationship with Robbins the events
described by all five women took place
in the 90s and early 2000s when Robbins
his Fame was skyrocketing and before he
married his second wife
secret recordings and transcripts from
inside his events revealed Robbins says
unleash expletive lated tirade on
survivors of rape
and domestic abuse domestic violence and
inviting them to share their stories in
front of a vast audience quote she's
[ __ ] using all this stuff to try and
control men he said after one woman said
she had been raped when in 2018 another
woman acute said her husband was
physically violent and emotionally
abusive Robbins accused her of quote
lying and asked does he put up with you
when you've been a crazy [ __ ] oh okay
this is a very long article and you know
everyone is able to read it I must read
the entire thing but this is breaking
today so we thought we should touch on
it um I mean I don't know Tony Robbins
he's a motivational speaker I don't know
why I thought it was like a Catholic
thing but maybe it's not I thought it
was it was had a religious element as
media but it just sounds like he's like
a motivational speaker like yeah for
everyone um so I guess there's no excuse
why I don't know he's from a shallow
hell yeah and you don't say this is no
surprise look at what he did to him in
that elevator he did great things but
you also like you know manipulated
someone's mind without giving them
permission this is really creepy these
are very serious allegations and I think
I mean he's so massive that if this is
all true this is it's like Scientology
vibes yeah it's like it's crazy but like
I don't know why I'm like not surprised
yeah like when you're so powerful and
like when your motivational speaker I
don't know I'm surprised but when you're
a motivational speaker or are like a
religious figure like you be get this
like god complex like people literally I
seen it on the Beermen stories they go
to it's like it's like a twelve-hour
like in an arena like session it's like
people [ __ ] ride-or-die for him so of
course it's gonna give you a complex if
people literally act like you're their
God but it also seems like a lot of this
stuff happy happened in the 90s when he
was coming up so it's like oh it's a
James Charles like power-hungry bromance
this is not James time this is if true
very very horrible
I'm gonna finish reading the article
after the show and I'll give you all my
thoughts tomorrow but just we wanted to
warn everyone stay away from Tony
Robbins yeah and read up because wow if
if this is true this this is major this
is he's because it's not even like he's
in a powerful position he's abusing his
power it's like his power is connected
to like changing people's lives
positively and like if it's the complete
office
right like that is it's like when Harvey
Weinstein is an abuser it's like okay he
was a movie maker and like an [ __ ]
right but he never actually like worked
on movies like it doesn't affect the way
we watch his movies you know but it's
like it's not like he was pretending to
be like the most positive life-changing
transformative guy right like the
victims of his abuse are victims for
sure but it's also like the countless
people who like invested their life in
him like and like beat him like they
like he became a part of their family
you know ya know it's like it's like a
Catholic Church situation where like
questions everything that you believe
totally okay that's all out in that
until tomorrow
next up lamar odom admits using fake
penis to pass Olympics truck tests okay
Lamar Odom's book is coming out and it
sounds lit and wild it make sounds like
a best-seller I know for sure and it
sounds like he's not holding back except
for the part where he's like keeps
talking about like cocaine like it was
the only thing that write it which we
spoke about yeah it may not be the
weirdest thing Lamar Odom has ever done
but in 2004 the NBA champ wore a
prosthetic penis to pass a drug test for
the upcoming Olympics in Athens Odom
makes the revelation in his new memoir
darkness to light according to People
magazine there was no way I was going to
pass the former husband of Khloe
Kardashian writes of the requisite drug
test I quote I had been smoking weed
every day that summer panic set in some
online research on how to beat a drum
beat a drug test led him to order quote
a giant rubber black
I think [ __ ] to arrive the next day he
wrote it scene with a - I'm assuming
that's [ __ ] at test time he asked his
trainer to donate a clean urine sample
fill the prosthetic and used it to fake
pee into a cup as a NBA security
official watch she admitted welcome to
Team USA the bamboozled official told
him also where in the memoir Odom and
meats admits that he began shooting on
Kardashians soon after the wedding quote
I couldn't keep my dick in my pants or
the coke out of my nose he writes
blaming the lethal cocktail of sudden
celebrity his diminishing NBA career and
his addiction Wow
I mean is it really that easy was the
official watching him and like they say
is the official complicit is here how no
I don't think so he sounds like he
fooled him but so he put on a penis on
his existing penis how close is the
official I think it's like a keychain
you maybe it's like it on your penis or
maybe it's like an angle thing like if
the officials here he could put the
penis to the left you see if you're
you have to go in a stall I guess the
gear it all makes it seem like you could
just do it anywhere no I think you still
like go in a bathroom like a human being
no I think they watch you were like from
the stall from behind you if you're in a
urinal okay so you're they're saying you
watch from behind so well because if he
needed a fake penis he could have just
put like a water bottle in his pocket if
he was going into the bathroom no it
looks like the man was watching the peen
yeah I'm a man or one yeah I need more
logistics here from Lamar like how big
was a stall was he outside how far away
was the official was that was the
prosthetic penis like a slide on did it
have the pee in it now I want to say
something controversial like does this
in any way impact the metals or the
standing of that year's team because
it's like in dodgeball when Bernice was
on steroids they were disqualified from
the semi-finals goddamn it Bernice so I
want to say that the same rule applies
here I don't know you know that's every
leg good question tomorrow's headline
will be after Lamar Odom shocking
revelation Team USA has to get his sack
yeah two gold medals from 2012 but
didn't he also participate in another
Olympics like cuz in Athens in 2004 I
didn't know who Lamar Odom was oh that's
what I remember he was in an Olympics
with LeBron they were wearing the Berets
from um from who was it Ralph Lauren I
think it was London maybe I don't know
was he clean then I don't know
interesting maybe they have to guess I
suppose a really long time book I just
ordered actually I just received as well
Howard Stern biography oh I didn't buy
autobiography I keep seeing headlines
about it which I don't mean so much to
me because like I don't know like so
much of Howard Stern's life and like I
whatever but I want to get to know it
because I think he's just like so
interesting that is a fascinating read
he is interesting yeah so I'm gonna read
it the book is so heavy and there was
only hardcover and like I don't know how
many carry it can we catch up on some
Brava shows that that was the past five
stories that you needed to know when
honestly you needed to know that
literally some days you don't need to
know them and we're pretty honest about
that but today you needed to know so
okay let's just start really easy with
like the low-hanging fruit in New York
nothing happened but I thoroughly enjoy
the episode I just I love these ladies
there's something about them that like
nothing can happen because
did happen but I just like really
enjoyed it I agree I found it
interesting about Barbara sexuality like
she was being really open about it yeah
yeah I disagree I thought the episode
actually a lot happened it was the first
interesting episode and it was giving
like up until now every single episode
of Housewives of New York has been
pretty much worthless
um because like the women don't even
hang out but that conversation at
Luann's house was just like they put it
up right in the middle to be consumed of
course because that's the only
interesting footage they have was
unbelievably telling and by the way that
thing was being such a good arguer she
was like that's how I choose to live my
life like you choose to be a cabaret sir
I choose to go home early and be with my
kid like why is yours more valuable than
mine no I'm a completely team Bethenny
Luann's being out of control out of
control even though I do have one thing
to say in defense of LuAnn that all the
women are getting on about her for not
coming down to the party before her
performance and it's like I couldn't
agree with that less she's a performer
what is she gonna do like hang out with
the kids they got the party at the bar
okay I don't agree with that but they
could have went up and she should've
invited they could have went up if
they're gonna be there for three hours
before she performs and she's gonna make
them stay down then she should go down
agree also it was a two song set at a
warehouse party it wasn't like she was
performing at Radio City and she's going
into the audio and her just like
demanding that Bethenny be there to
celebrate her successes because Bethenny
helped her it's like no Bethenny did
enough for you [ __ ] off and her
insisting that the party was fabulous
and they should have been enjoying
themselves the party was not fabulous
jegi
her insisting that her house is fabulous
and they should all like be jealous of
her the house was not fabulous yeah it
was just like a lot of no it's like no
one can like talk straight to her and
like she's being very count to see yeah
but you know what she's also keeping the
show interesting so I'm not very fun I'm
not mad about it but I'm shocked that
she's behaving that way after everything
that she's been through yeah it's like
it's a complete lack of self-awareness
that's making for great television but
not making for good friendships no and
like last season like I I rode hard for
Bethenny and LuAnn yeah and that that
version of me a year ago me is upset but
I was also upset by this whole season so
far so present me is grateful for not me
to like I'm really like holding out for
like a Bethenny and LuAnn like
friendship that lasts a lifetime and
while we're not getting that I'm
try and remember where we came from lyon
matt married man like it could be so
much worse in terms of Bethenny LuAnn
relationship so I'm grateful for where
we're at don't become a long way you
know it's we're going down a dark road
now and now we're getting to life is not
a cabaret and I don't know where they
stand today but LuAnn owes a lot of
apologies and I don't that's not her
strong suit and you know it's been a
while since we've had but uh LuAnn at a
reunion and they just fate film the
runion and I do think it would be really
interesting because she does a lot to
answer for from last season to yeah like
she was gone yeah but she's not
that's not her thing is because
answering you know and she's a lot but I
think she gets uh firmly Savannah
problem um we need to talk about Dorinda
oh my gosh so Dorinda talking about her
new neighborhood she was gonna cry every
morning she wakes up I was just I was
laughing so I was like I didn't know how
to feel then the next day I'm walking
down the street and this man's walking
in the opposite direction of me and I
just recognize his mustache and I'm like
how do I know that mustache and it was
the florist that she lets up talking
about his mustache I literally like
freaked out he was on the night before
and like I wanted to go and take the
picture I'm like put it in the toasters
but I just said snot that's not my
strong suit
um but I was like I was so - hysterical
but they're just doing so many weird
scenes this season like like so in-depth
Ramona shopping at Jonathan Adler like
literally like ten minutes because
there's not a lot going on like but I
want to go into more about Ramona and
her second set of friends because that's
fascinating yeah and Sonja is like in
her own way she's like a weirdo but
she's very clear and very lucid on
Ramona and how Ramona treats his women
like her second-tier friends even though
at the end of the day like they're
really gonna be the only ones who are
gonna be there for the end of the day
and he's like fake Fairweather socialite
friends that she has who are throwing
her birthday party who she met at the
angel ball like are not real yeah hey
I'm stories from Nantucket I did well
get into but I just want to say maybe I
love playing devil's out if you get
Ramona because she doesn't ever explain
herself so it just leaves everything up
into interpretation maybe here's a
scenario her her socialite friends want
to throw her this birthday at Scarpetta
if she invites the girls can have
cameras will come they don't want that
Ramona doesn't want that I mean not in
Ramona of course wants that they don't
want that she can invite the girls maybe
just Sonya but then maybe they'll still
film so now
it's a fair assessment I need to talk
about Ramona and then tuck it this
weekend being black out being black out
with dr. Sharon Jeezy yeah but you're
the bathroom mm you know your name yeah
oh no I didn't I only saw her on the
plane oh my god no Jackie she's standing
in the bathroom in Nantucket trying to
show that like Nantucket still beautiful
cuz you could be in the bathroom stall
and you hear the waves okay and she
can't speak
she is slur go to the Mexico City - it's
hysterical she like got lit as [ __ ] and
Tucker this weekend do you want to go
back to Nantucket not at all like there
are many places I never want to go to
either lines' know one of them and so is
Nantucket I think we should go back to
Nantucket at some point maybe we may
have kids like they would like it and
only like the way Ramona does it cuz she
did it a bigger oh but that's where we
experienced and then we didn't
experience anti-semitism in and then
tuck it we just felt very Jewish yeah
like we were like self-consciously and
we felt really out of place yeah okay
really that was all that happened I
don't think there's anything else to
discuss in terms of Beverly no and in
terms of New York oh but Ramona's saying
I wish you just skipped the after-party
for Victoria's Secret oh she said there
he was like are you [ __ ] kidding me
like that you would know not that red
carpet little bit around would you
adverb it's a red carpet to come to my
fake charity event it was pure comedy it
was truly it's Ramona before we had the
deacon
I think she is oh I want to check my
Beverly Hills and I wanted to ask you a
touring related question because I was
watching Erica's show yeah and I loved
it and I always think of LuAnn and what
she's doing and what's so iconic about
it and successful is the fact that she
brings the Real Housewives experience
IRL it's like a traveling real House
Museum and fans of the show can go and
be a part of like Real Housewives yeah
and I was like she's the first and only
housewife to really do that but then I
was like no Erika Jayne does that and
her shows her shows are a come to life
Real Housewives experience and what I
mean I've never seen either show
actually so I can't speak to it but I
feel like Erika Jayne you know she she's
there in the whole time she's a
performer etc she has the whatever yeah
they wrote their great shows I'm sure
it's different but both high level of
production so how come Erika
a store for her is maybe like a chose in
like ish small baggie was like less than
a thousand people at the globe from a
touring perspective what is the
difference and why is Luann's so much
lower tor is like and I think like this
is why she's gotten such a big head it's
super legit like I follow along with it
just cuz I'm like interested and I feel
like anytime she goes to a market it's a
really good test for me like cuz we have
a similar audience it's on a smaller
scale so she started out just doing a
bunch of shows and like turned a lot of
heads and like the random venue she
would do and she would sell a ton of
tickets and her entire tour guide picked
up my Live Nation so like they're
booking they're doing the venue is their
negotiating her deal so like her her
tour is completely legit it's way more
legit than mine it's just as legit as
any other cabaret star but there was no
other cabaret star but it's very it's
top-tier like she is the best promoters
the best I've been used the best
everything like she's really and that's
just based on a few shows where the
sales were crazy I'm the only thing
people in live events slash like
concerts care about is ticket selling
like if you sell tickets people will
look here so that's why I Luann's is so
legit with Erica's I don't know if it's
not that it's a priority for her or
there's just not as much demand but it's
just not nearly as big it was I saw on
the marquee it said fullscreen position
which is not nearly as top-tier as like
nomination Live Nation AEG golden voice
would they do Coachella there's like so
it full screens like a digital I don't
know but I wonder I just wonder why I
feel like maybe she doesn't like she
doesn't like she doesn't shows because I
gots Erika Jayne but like she doesn't
want to be touring yeah and I think it's
not her own like LuAnn latched on to
this cabaret thing because like it was
getting her out of jail it was paying
her child but it was everything this
tour had to work for the man for Erika
it's like one of a million things that
makes her money and it's probably the
hardest and probably makes her the least
amount of money that makes sense okay I
feel I feel better even though like her
I would love to see an Erika Jayne
concert that was a great episode it was
really just like a lot of filler but I
had such a good time like I felt like I
was there it looked like such a fun show
I did you go to one of her show I had
such a good time in the episode I agree
until the last minute where Lisa
Vanderpump
looks to be taking a lie detector test
oh my god that looks so stupid and you
know what Camille she was really pissing
me off because she was acting at Lisa
Vanderpump's house and then saying stuff
in confessionals to totally opposite
things because if I just want
interview I was like I mean if I just
watched her time at least that's how she
really understood and she didn't wasn't
upset that Lisa wasn't gonna come to the
wedding and truly felt like the women
were villainizing and victimizing and
you know really she's a two-faced and
then another [ __ ] interview she's
being so two-faced like of all the
things that I don't like at her at least
she's been like so like real like coming
after Teddy and like really being like
open with jury like but she's been such
a little two-faced little [ __ ] to Lisa
Vanderpump is really pissed me off
no is piss me off she's going as
two-faced oh my god the kitchen I just
can't it's great it looks great no I
mean I can't wait their animations but
no I'm glad we got to see the final
kitchen because I'm obsessed yeah it's
so beautiful I love the episode without
her like I just can only like now
imagine a world where Vanderpump is not
on Beverly Hills and it seems amazing
yeah and then southern charm oh okay you
know what I really I've just I really
like slept on southern charm for a while
but I got heavily involved last year
when Ashley Jacobs came over here and
manipulated us and then two days later
like Thomas Ravenel went to jail being
accused of rape and it's so interesting
how they have to talk about this like
big elephant in the room and him and her
like not be there which I like because
you know what I don't need to hear their
side like they're crazy and disgusting
and I'm like happy just and we've been
hearing his side for the last six
seasons and it's he's a liar the only
some in the way there is like it's
finally like okay it's Catherine's like
comeuppance like finally like it's been
years of like everyone talking [ __ ] Tom
it's like really like pulling the wool
over the eyes of everyone and everyone
turning on Kathryn I'm like this is her
year like they bring in this girl yeah
why because they need a seminarian and
when Kathryn and like obviously this
girl comes in and like everyone who goes
toe-to-toe with Kathryn like makes it
onto the season and when Kathryn was
like my coattails are just about worn
out I was like that was literally all
she had to say and that was exactly what
this girl was doing which is trying to
antagonize Kathryn to become a part of
the store then because like everyone
else at Cameron you know pretty even
like level-headed Kathryn has always had
these really big reactions even when
she's just pushed a little bit but one
eliza needs to realize she's not that
girl anymore and so she thought that she
was and like if she says something to
copy and she'll get a reaction and there
she's in the scene but Kathryn is not
playing these games and I can't believe
right now I'm like totally shipping
Kathryn and Whitney when they're
time when like I literally wanted to
throw him in jail for they'll be here
creepy no I know I'm he's like such a
weird character cuz like he's like not
on the show he's such a weird cat mom is
on the show more than he and he's an
executive producer of the show he's
always been he like came up with the
concept for the show it's so weird to me
so he like got him he got the show off
the grounds like took a step back
because people did not like him because
he was a stupid character I don't know
how to how I feel about him I don't know
if I've ever met him maybe that's like
why I don't know how I feel about him
because I am only going based on TV um I
think with southern charm it's like I'm
obsessed with all the guys on the show
like I think Austin is so hot and like I
just love him and I'm just like not here
for this like weird girl that he's
dating oh I kind of here for her I think
it's so hilarious
do you see our macho happens live no you
didn't mitchell Tenpenny bartending
episode with patricia and catherine has
the guest and then madison was in the
audience and like as Annie's have some
heard ton of questions cuz he's like so
invested in this threesome drama and
she's like responding and Austin's
tweeting and they're literally fighting
and they're still together and they're
fighting on TV via Andy why wasn't she
with him um I don't know why she came
alone it was weird but I'm kind of
liking her because like she's at like
awesome cheat on her so she cheated on
him and by the way they were on a break
and the fan chef was wrong about the
chef was totally wrong but like the
girls should get to act like the guys
yeah these like so I like her I like her
you know what's so interesting is and I
didn't even put together till the very
end it's like okay so Cameron we're
adjusting to her new life as a mom and
she's complaining a lot and it's like
okay Katherine's a mom too you know so I
feel like we need some more like mom
content with the two of them and they
should really be bonding now they are
the know they are bonding Katherine went
over to her house last season they
talked about mom Stephanie was actually
kind of a nice scene I think with
Katherine and the kids this season it's
all about like custody yeah and it's
like so much more than just mom content
and Craig while I'm really happy for him
he really seems to be in a good place
his apartment looks awesome and I'm
really happy did you see last season's
yes okay he like needs to like hop off
of Naomi stick and like stop acting like
Naomi's kept up at night by the thought
of Craig because it's just like so not
true and her boyfriends like so cute
he's a doctor it's like she's doing fine
so well I'm happy for him he's annoying
me and they are so in shaped like I felt
like a [ __ ] slob no total watching
network 511 he just keeps addressing her
new nose because
you know totally she looks I'm so happy
for her and I personally ship to Craig
and Naomi but I understand that it's not
the ship has sailed
so I'm happy for Naomi and I think
Craig's dating someone now but not the
girl that he brought no who does he
bring again some Rando and I love how
he's like wow she's so pretty like that
yes no you're human secure yeah you're
so secure and like you're not an ass
holding like you're not a like a [ __ ]
and and they made it seem like Naomi
didn't say hi because she was like
feeling awkward no she's staying
Patricia's couch and she was freaking
the [ __ ] out but the second she got an
upgrade she said hi
I tried to paint it like she was me
weird and she was it because she was
didn't care about the champagne and I
totally understood because a lot of
things you don't want to do and staining
Patricia's couch is one of them and
here's the thing about Patricia because
I've said horrible things on the show
only to match the things that she said
about Catherine and now that her in
Catherine her friends you would think I
would back off and and you know what I'm
definitely backing off a little bit but
there's just something innately evil
about her the fact that she has
supported Thomas all this time you you
know him like you knew him you can't
pretend like he pulled the wool over
eyes you're a smart woman like you came
around the block have some
accountability and now she just wants to
completely promote Catherine and say I'm
not fully buying it like you you enabled
Thomas like you completely like what
Thomas did to Katherine was horrible but
what Patricia did to her like
society-wide sure she allowed it like
just piled on yeah and her sitting at a
table with like a bunch of 25 year-olds
like it's weird
it is weird and like I is weird and they
can frame it as much as they want it's
like Whitney's coming home party but
it's not it's weird and you know what
I'm not here for it I don't like
Patricia except I did watch literally
two hours of a skinny confidential story
visiting her house and it was
fascinating and I was loving it from
like her being this like socialite like
in this like historic iconic socialite I
love that angle but her also being like
a [ __ ] starter on a reality show for 20
year olds I'm not into know but I it's
not every day that we get a historical
socialite who's open to reality TV so
like for that reason I appreciate her
presence but it's like focus more on the
historical socialite aspect not just
like the [ __ ] hanging out was 25 year
olds giving bad advice to her son and
his rapist friend no totally like I'm
just I'm not ready
I didn't even get an apology you know so
I can't even I'm not ready to forgive
nor have I been asked to write because
she like has the unique situation where
she's never really on a reunion she
doesn't have to like speak for herself
her answer for her actions it's not
right and that's what she has such a
heavy hand in everything that she really
it's all she's a small character she's a
huge importing character she's a huge
importing hydrous she she pulls
Whitney's puppet strings Whitney's an
executive producer whatever Patricia
wants will happen to Kathryn what
happened to anyone she could get
probably get someone off the show and
that's what she tried to do to Kathryn
and so I could see in a year from now me
being like wow I can't believe I once
hated Patricia I love her because I'm
supposed to love her like she's
everything she's iconic her clothes her
dogs her butler her house etc like it's
all wonderful and I know I'm supposed to
love it as much as Lady Gaga loves her I
just I need some sort of like
accountability for the fact that like
you almost completely destroyed this
young girl's life protecting this older
man who by the way didn't even have a
good history and who who didn't Prince
felon and who's a felon and didn't ever
act like he wasn't what he was he always
made these comments he was always just
like this slurring [ __ ] and you
allowed him to do that so I just I need
some accountability on that front maybe
we'll get it this season before I
completely turn I agree and those are my
thoughts okay well what a wild episode a
roller coaster of emotions he was a plan
for this week we're back tomorrow
Tuesday Wednesday as well Thursday as
well and then right after Thursday's
episode we are driving to camp toast
so Friday's episode will be a camp toast
episode which will be for the community
of camp toasters and also our Pietra
members so if you want to listen to the
camp toast episodes this weekend
make sure to head over to the patreon
calm down on patreon.com slash the
morning toast it for a good time anyways
we will see you tomorrow have a great
day
you